d to Berlin,
d to Berlin.
Of course what the Socialist Party has been saying,
Pedro Sanchez.
Concordia,
.
And of course,
that there was no terrorism.
As the regular himself said at that meal.
The same,
Concord?
Of course you do,
Concordia.
But Concordia is made before the citizens,
defends itself against the Spaniards
and not of the recording,
not behind the scenes with 16 journalists.
Concordia,
which is,
which is coexistence,
demands courage,
eh,
courage to go out to the citizens to say so,
that this is what is convenient.
What Pedro has done.
And I'm telling you,
because vesteiro is like that.
To manage 1 country,
to lead 1 community,
you need to be decent,
as is Pedro y Vesteiro,
and brave as Pedro Sanchez and Vesteiro is.